In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 8th, on which we commemorate the nativity
of the Theotokos.
On the 8th of the month we celebrate the nativity of our sovereign lady, the most holy mother
of God and ever virgin Mary.
One was made by God and placed in paradise that his soul care might be to bring forth
good fruit and to contemplate God, his Creator, through his works.
But Adam was driven out of the garden of delights, through the envy of the devil, who
deceived Eve, the first woman, and caused Adam to sin.
Later, God gave the law to men by Moses and made known his will by the prophets in preparation
for the greater blessing of the incarnation of his only Son, the Word of God, who would
deliver us from the nets of the evil one.
In taking our nature upon himself, Christ wished to share fully our fallen state, but without
sin.
For he alone is without sin, being the Son of God.
For this reason, he prepared for himself a spotless habitation, an immaculate ark, the
most holy virgin Mary, who, although she too was subject to death and the condemnation of
our first parents, yet she was chosen by God before all ages to be the new Eve.
The mother of Christ, the Savior, the wellspring of our redemption and the archetype of all Christian
holiness.
On her father's side, the most holy virgin Mary, was of the royal line of David, through
his son Nathan, who begot Levi, who begot Melkai, and Panther, who begot Bar Panther, who
begot Joachim, who was the father of the mother of God.
Anna, the wife of Joachim, was also of David's lineage, for she was the granddaughter of Matha,
who was himself the grandson of David through Solomon.
Matha married a certain Mary of the tribe of Judah, and they had a son named Jacob, the father
of Joseph, the carpenter, and three daughters, Mary, Sylvia, and Anna.
Mary gave birth to Salome, the midwife, Sylvia to Elizabeth, the mother of the forerunner,
and Anna to the mother of God.
God in his wisdom showed the Baroness of human nature before the coming of Christ, by leaving
Joachim and Anna, childless, until they were very old.
Joachim, who was both rich and devout, prayed without ceasing, and offered gifts to God,
that he would deliver his wife and himself from their reproach among men.
One feastay, he had gone to the temple to present his offering, when one of the congregation
of the tribe of Ruben turned to him and said, You are not allowed to offer with us, because
you have no child.
These words cut Joachim to the heart, and instead of returning home, he went up into a mountain
alone to pray and weep, while at the same hour Anna too was shedding abundant tears and
fervently imploring heaven.
Our God who is rich in mercy and full of compassion, heard their entreaties, and sent the messenger
of His benevolence and herald our salvation, the archangel Gabriel to Anna.
He announced that she would conceive in her old age and bear a child, who would be the
praise of the whole earth, full of joy and amazement, she exclaimed, As the Lord my God
lives, whether the child I bear be a son or a daughter, I will consecrate it to the Lord
my God to serve him all the days of his life.
Joachim too was visited by an angel and told to lead his flocks homeward and to rejoice with
his wife and all their house, because God had determined to put an end to their reproach.
When nine months had passed, Anna gave birth and asked the midwife, whom have I brought into
the world?
A daughter she replied, My soul has been magnified this day, exclaimed Anna, and gently
laid the child down.
And when the days of her purification according to the law were accomplished, she arose, washed,
gave suck to the child and called her Mary, the name obscurally awaited by the patriarchs,
the prophets and the righteous and by which God would reveal the mystery hidden from all
eternity.
The child grew strong and her mother placed her on the ground when she was six months old
to see if she would stand up.
Confidently, Mary took seven paces and then turned back and clung to her mother's breast.
Anna lifted her up, saying, As the Lord my God lives, you shall tread on the ground no more
until I take you into the temple of the Lord.
Her mother kept the room where the child was as a holy place, and no unlovely or unclean
thing entered there, and she brought daughters of Hebrews of pure lineage to play with
the child.
When the child was one year old, Joachim gave a great feast.
He invited the priests, the scribes, and all the counsel and people of Israel.
He presented Mary to the priests, and they blessed her, saying, God of our fathers blessed
this child, and give her an everlasting name to be named of all generations.
And all the people responded, Let it be so, let it be so, Amen.
Joachim also presented her to the high priest, who blessed her, saying, God of infinite majesty
looked down upon this little child and grant her a blessing, supreme and beyond compare.
Then her mother carried Mary into the holy place kept for her, and gave her the breast, singing
to the Lord this hymn.
I will sing to the Lord my God, for he has visited me, and taken away the reproach of my enemies,
for the Lord has given me the fruit of his righteousness, at once simple and multiple, in its operation.
Who will now tell it to the sons of Rubin that Anna is a mother?
Learn, learn you twelve tribes of Israel that Anna is a mother.
Then she left the child in the holy place, reserved for her, and went out to serve the guests,
who rejoiced and praised the God of Israel.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.